hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the fide grand prix 2022 being played
in berlin uh in a match between hikaru
nakamura and levon arunyan it's uh well
uh
one of the matchups that you guys have
been requesting and uh well basically we
would enjoy seeing anyone in the finals
but uh nakamura and levon just have a
very special place in our hearts as we
all know uh and it's very interesting to
see how hikaru will do against such a
such a super grandmaster and also a
former member of the 2800 club after
being away from classical chess for so
long now uh so far it seems like being
away from classical uh is good for your
game uh but we'll see how he uh deals uh
against lebon he car has the white
pieces let's check out the game uh he
opens with pawn to e4 uh we have e5 by
levon knight to f3 knight to c6 and
bishop to b5 going for the for the rue
lopez we have a6 uh the uh morphy's
defense we have bishop to a4 and now
knight to f6 uh we have castles and
bishop to e7 the columbus variation uh
was on the board but now with bishop to
a7 we go
into the closed royal opus we have rook
to e1 adding a defender to the pawn here
and now b5 so this is all very very
standard stuff
a lot of games in the database with this
exact same lines with castles h3 bishop
to b7 and now d3 and d6 again nothing
new here uh we have a3 and now queen to
d7 developing the queen connecting the
rooks with knight to c3 and now knight
the d8 freeing up
that
c pawn
so you can push it and also the knight
is coming to e6 and from there maybe to
d4 or f4 depending on what white plays
and here uh almost everyone plays d4 in
this position you've removed the
defender of the d4 square so naturally
white will play
d4 here but hikaru actually goes knight
to the h2 and it is now uh already as of
move 12 did we have a completely new
game yeah so let's see how levon uh
continues with knight to e6 now the
knight can come to f4 if uh if it so
pleases we have knight to g4 offering a
trade of knights and here uh levon plays
king to h8 and it's a very tricky move
because uh well if he car trades then
levon might be even interested in
capturing with the g pawn and that could
be uh could be very scary for both white
and black so here hikaru does capture he
kind of wants a levon to play this but
maybe it's too too risky and next game
he has the white pieces so maybe next
game uh he he can push for for more uh
so uh we will just show it the g
captures an f6 can be played and then
you get the semi-open g file to be used
for your rooks you can play rook g8
maybe rouge g6 bringing the other rook
to g8 the bishop is very nicely placed
on b7 uh the queen already controlling
this diagonal it's uh it's a very
enjoyable position but could be also
very bad for you so instead after knight
captures an f6 levon just recaptures
with the bishop and now queen g4 hikaru
brings the queen into the game rook ate
the e8 uh for the moment um
uh you don't have to worry about even
though okay the knight can't really move
because the queen hangs unless you play
something like knight to c5 uh but uh
for the moment uh nah not worried about
that so rook eight to e8 we have a4 now
he carves strikes on the queen side he
wants to play something like captures
captures maybe bring the rook over to a7
and now b4 live on uh wants to keep the
uh the queen side close we have knights
to e2 and now queen to d8 i'm pinning so
now the knight can move uh wherever
pretty much we've c3 now charging the b4
pawn also offering a trade here so you
can execute d4 in the future b captures
on c3 with b captures and g6 now and g6
is a very important move uh you wanna be
able to bring your uh your bishop back
to g7 also maybe you will be interested
in bringing the knight here and then to
f4 uh maybe you can just bring the
knight to f4 right away uh but also you
are preventing the white knight from
going something like knight g3 to f5 so
all in all it's a very useful move uh
and now uh you could capture the knight
here that it's that's perfectly fine
because um the knight could be a scarier
piece than the bishop on b3 also some
other ideas are possible but here uh we
have bishop to d5 very interesting by
hikaru attacking the bishop on b7 and
levon very happily trades as he will
double up he carries a
e pawn to a d pawn so bishop captures
pawn captures and now knight to c5 not
going just for the d3 pawn also knight
to b3 might be interesting in some lines
uh but hikaru invites this and he plays
bishop to h6 so here hikaru is offering
the d3 pawn for some very interesting
counter play and of course levon could
decline the secret place just bishop the
g7 then we could see something like
captures captures uh and it could be
very interesting uh for lebon if let's
say queen c4 you put some pressure on on
black spawns here we can just play e4 so
that's also also very nice for black as
uh the the knight now and the rook
control the e4 pawn uh not all that much
you can play here of course pushing d
for uh resulting knight to d3 so that's
also good for black so it's an option
but levon decides to grab the pawn he
says all right i will take your pawn and
then we'll see
where this game goes we have bishop
captures on f8 knight capture sunny one
rook captures and of course rook
captures an f8 so some pieces have been
traded off lavon is now up a pawn
and hikaru goes queen to c4 now puts
pressure on the a6 pawn uh and levon
says all right i was planning on on
defending this so queen to a8 and now he
offers the c7 pawn for the d5 pawn but
this would be uh this would be better
for black so maybe and not not the
greatest uh of ideas but uh if you don't
play that what what do you play he car
plays rook to b1 makes sense it's the
only open file on the board and of
course levon offers a trade rook to b8
also activating the rook rook the b4 now
saying okay i would very much enjoy if
you captured on b4 so i can improve my
pawn structure here and later on play
some like b5 uh so here levon could
really consider a move like a5 and force
a trade on the b file and then play
against maybe the the isolated a pawn uh
but uh he first goes king to g7 and okay
hikaru goes knight g3 he wants to play
knight to e4 and uh well this will
improve the position of his knight
immensely so here h5 element says i'm
not too worried about this i have ids of
a5 i have ids of h4 so it's a you know a
a very dynamic position so knight to e4
attacking the bishop here and levon just
brings the bishop back bishop to d8 and
now as lavon uh did not play a5 for for
so long he car now plays a5 and it looks
a little bit dangerous because well the
pawn can maybe easily be attacked but
not really you never want to push c6 or
c5 it's just uh very ugly allowing this
uh pawn to become a pass pawn would be
incredibly dangerous you could however
try rook to c8 avoid the rook trade
altogether put the rook on the c file
and then push the c pawn uh but levon
has different ideas he plays rook queen
to a7
uh and now we have g3 by hikar we have
f5 now uh grabbing more more space on
the king side attacking the knight
knight to d2 and only now rook captures
on b4 hikaru is very happy with this uh
recent development we have c captures on
b4 now with b5 hikaru is very sure that
a pass pawn will be created either by
black capturing on b5 or just by
capturing an a6 then this pawn becomes a
pass pawn so here levon uh strikes with
e4 and now knight to b3 now the knight
can come to d4 and then maybe the c6 or
e6 could be very very dangerous so
bishop to f6 of course not allowing this
so we are taking away that square from
the white knight and now king to g2 just
improving the position and now we have
h4 uh so trying to bust open the
position here and he cover captures this
because it's the best move and for the
moment black cannot recapture this
recapturing here uh would in fact lose
the game for the one but it's a very
nice line so we're going to show eddie
flavon captures on h4 then we have this
uh beautiful queen trade queen d4 check
now a queen trade is forced you don't
have any options here captures captures
and there is no defense against b5
that's why this two to one uh advantage
on the queen side is uh just incredibly
strong even though there's a backwards c
pawn which kind of makes it uh hard for
for you to do something with the b-pawn
but still it just works by force here
whatever black plays we're just going to
push upon and after captures a6 and the
pawn is unstoppable uh whatever you do
we're just going to advance the pawn you
are far too late to stop the pawn so
instead after g captures an h4 first a
nice king to f7 and now we have h5 now
hikaru says all right if you want to
recapture you will mess up your own pawn
structure so g captures on h5 and now he
car plays b5 and with this b5 pawn push
he creates a pass pawn so e3 levon needs
to get some counter play very quickly
and now comes f4
uh securing some squares here and also
the king will uh try try to stop the
pawn maybe you can play king king f1 or
f3 and followed by king to e2 uh but uh
uh time is very low on the clock uh the
it's already moved 39 so we still need
to make one more move to reach time
control and hikaru is already below one
minute
whereas levon is closer to some 10
minutes on the clock so hikaru needs to
be very careful and levon plays queen to
b8 which is very interesting he gives
hikaru an option here okay you're
incredibly low on time do you want to
capture here and create a pass pawn i
mean it's a free pawn maybe you should
capture it uh the problem is there's
just not enough time for hikaru to
calculate this even though he calculates
extremely fast but if you capture the
pawn then you allow this queen to ga to
check and now you have problems uh if
you go king to h1 well king to h1 is
good but let's say you go kink the f1 uh
then king queen to g3 threatens
checkmate attacks the h3 pawn which
comes with check is just very ugly so
you're gonna have to play king to h1 but
still we're gonna play queen g3 and you
do not want to have this position if
queen f1 to to guard everything uh we
just play e2 that's how we break through
queen captures queen captures on b3 now
you're down at night and all in all with
best play this should be a draw but
still it's a lot a lot to calculate with
just uh needing to make one move to
reach time control uh and with less than
a minute on the clock so hikaru just
played king to f1 he stepped away from
the g file so this doesn't come with
check also you are very close to
stopping that pawn and now okay a
captures on b5 this is move 40 both
players have reached it and now
additional time is received so queen to
c6 hikaru has a passport now if he can
play a6 queen to b7 and a7 a8 of course
the game is over so levon cannot allow
this he plays e2 with check he wants to
give up this pawn to be able to get the
queen into the game with tempo and you
don't really gain anything if you play
k1 if you don't capture it we can play
queen e7 and the white is not in time to
play a6 because there's just queen to g1
and you're not uh
you know uh
escaping the chicks so here you might as
well capture the pawn so king captures
an e2 queen to a7 uh and now a6 uh of
course we we have to try uh queen to g1
by lavon now queen captures on c7 with
check king to g6 now knight to d2 the
knight is a very nice defender here next
to the king so the black queen will not
have an easy time
uh delivering all the checks so queen to
h2 check king to d1 now queen captures
on f4 grabbing this pawn so now the f5
pawn becomes a pass pawn but now a7 by
hikaru so how can levon prevent uh well
just losing the game uh bishop to g5 now
levon threatens checkmate and hikaru has
to deal with this now comes queen to a5
the only move to stop checkmate
uh and now the one plays b4 uh now the
queen no longer blocks checkmate so you
are threatening checkmate once again
queen to a2 defending against checkmate
and now even b3 now again if queen
captures we just check made the white
king so what can you do you could
capture the pawn with the knight but
this is again very tricky if knight
captures on b3 queen f1 check look at
the queen and bishop
were just working very nicely together
king c2 queen to f2 check king to b1 and
now we can play queen e1 check king b2
and now queen e to check and it doesn't
seem like you can checkmate the white
king for example uh king to a3 but then
we get a nice repetition queen a6 check
king back queen here and and so on so
also a lot of other moves that the white
can play uh will also result in in a
perpetual so knight captures on b3 isn't
all that much so queen to a5 just
guarding the knight and still okay the
knight prevents the queen from coming to
f1 but now levon doesn't really have uh
much of a much of an option here he
plays queen to e3 he allows hikaru to
bring a second queen into the game but
he will get his queen to g1 checking
with the pawn covering the c2 square uh
this is now all very very clear so
hikaru does bring the queen into the
game it's the best move uh queen g1
check we have king the e2 queen to e3
with check and king to d1 not a lot you
can play king to f1 is also possible but
it doesn't really do all that much uh
you you can try it but still i
you will not be able to to escape this
uh even queen captures an h3 and again
it's still gonna be a perpetual so he
doesn't wanna
he doesn't wanna lose this game because
it's very easy to you know make a
mistake in a position like this so here
just king d1 queen g1 check king to e2
queen e3 check and he was in this
position on 54 uh that hikara and levon
agreed to a draw yeah as there is
nothing more to be done here so a very
very interesting fighting game in the
first clash in the finals of the fiji
grand prix we'll see what happens in the
in the comeback match where levon will
have the white pieces and he will of
course do everything in his power to win
the game with white will hikar be able
to stop it and will we see uh tie bricks
in the finals uh so yeah uh that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it really a
wonderful start to the finals uh i would
like to thank david kimura meadow
francis air the emoji pillow on my couch
and mr hoodie guy for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the finals of
the video grand prix until it finishes
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day